Doot,
doot,
doot.
That clock at all.
Stope right.
We're live.
We're back.
Part two folks.
If you hated part one,
this one's going to be worse.
Worse,
worse.
Oh fucking hate to show.
You know what my favorite is when people go fucking shows change man.
You used to used to fucking be more open minded.
Yeah.
People Change.
Do you want me to do man,
I changed.
I changed over five years.
Everyone change.
I'm not into fucking Lego's and video games,
man.
I grew up.
I definitely don't think I'm less open minded though.
I'm definitely less tolerant for stupid shit though.
I just think I've heard it too many times now.
I'm like,
stop,
stop.
It's not doing anybody any good stock.
He cut out the bullshit.
Well I cut out like conspiracy bullshit and religious bullshit.
It's like,
and it doesn't mean that I,
I dunno,
I'm not willing to consider people's points of view,
but certain certain things just at a certain point in time like keep,
can't keep refreshing them shimmy over and over again.
You know when it gets a certain point in time,
like for instance,
like,
like Ufos.
Do?
I think the UFOS are real.
It's totally possible if we can put a satellite around the earth,
it's very possible at some advanced life form consent.
The spaceship here from another galaxy.
Have I seen anything that makes me believe that it's actually helped?
Proof?
No.
So when you don't share that opinion,
when you're absolutely convinced that the government is hiding details and like,
okay,
what makes you really want to believe this?
Because you're not saying this based on some hardcore shit.
Like I know that if you take this plastic and you put it over fire,
oops,
did I fuck that up?
If we take this plastic,
how did I do that?
Exit.
Take this plastic.
Oh,
what the fuck?
You can't
watch it now.
Jesus Christ.
If you take this plastic and put it over fire,
right?
What are they doing?
They're playing this again.
What are they doing here?
I didn't start this from the beginning.
Did I know that's a filler for rain?
They're showing this fight again.
The old filler fight.
Well,
we watched all,
we already watched his fight.
Do we watch on the video?
Was this on the,
um,
the prelims for the,
was it,
okay.
So I guess we watched this again.
Can you do,
maybe I'm wrong.
Is this a tournament?
It's not a toy.
It is.
It is a tournament.
A heavyweight tournament.
Oh,
that's right.
So this guy one early,
he's the number one ranked heads shaking shit.
Look at that little dance.
Oh,
look at him.
Go.
Oh Damn.
Look at him.
He's feeling good.
He's feeling it.
Look at his training in the back.
Awkward.
One of what?
Music.
He's dancing too because white people in me.
Guess let me guess how bad the song is.
Probably the worst song ever.
Let's hear what song is it?
Awesome.
I want to hear the song I hear quadros
sounds like some Rick Ross.
Really?
Some people want to believe
it is.
By the way.
I want to call me Quadro skeletor.
I was just choking.
He does look like him though a little bit,
but call a spade a spade.
I'm a Oh hi.
I got goofy.
I'm not,
but he does look like skeletor.
He's very knowledgeable though.
Knows a lot of shit about kickboxing.
Yeah.
Great man.
It's still a fixed kill it or
how dare you.
Oh,
Bravo.
He nasty problems like some serious beef back in the day.
I want to talk about it.
Oh.
Should have been talking about.
I'll tell you afterwards.
Is it legit beef though?
It's horse shit.
It's all stupidity.
Don't let it Eddie.
Oh,
stupidity.
Oh No,
no,
no.
And then not like that and like not like they come to that.
It was like gossip.
Yeah.
I'll tell you that.
I'm down for that.
Yeah,
definitely.
Tell me how to do.
Hey,
people change,
people grow and they move on.
Um,
speaking of growing and moving on,
what
segue in between the fight,
you,
you a,
you might've mentioned something that you might've wanted it to.
Yeah,
I'd rather it come from me first,
especially on this platform then from anyone else.
Uh,
things have just got too crazy man.
It's like the perfect storm and the UFC wanted me to sign the,
you know,
the license deal with Reebok and uh,
the,
the random testing,
the Vata testing,
where the fuck it is.
And really I was just going to ride this out and you know,
I wanted to do one more fight,
but with the fighter and the kid I'll craziest to become and I,
I never thought it'd become this and the live shows and now we're going on tour
and I have this,
this other gig.
I got this on a big network that I can't talk about till it's done.
And um,
the merchandise and all this stuff,
it,
it just,
I got to step away from the game,
man.
I gotta step away from the UFC for right now.
You know what I love about fighting?
We were talking about this,
that you could just say,
I'm going to retire.
And then you could say like in a week from now I'm unretired and then a week
later you could say retired again.
Yeah,
you could go back and forth for sure.
But like,
thinking about sugar Ray Leonard,
how many times does a coal miner retire?
Usually once she won sugar ray Leonard.
No tired.
Like a half a dozen fucking time.
Get it with fighters,
man.
But for me,
you know,
and I,
I talked to my family and close friends and you were one of them and Callan and
you know,
my dad and,
uh,
going through it,
man,
it just do I want one more?
Fuck yes man.
But it just,
it doesn't make sense.
I,
I can't see myself in it when it comes down.
This,
I can't see myself in a fucking Reebok kit walking out to the octagon.
I can't see myself being like,
you know what?
Cool man.
Yeah,
that's what I'm worth.
I'm worth 10 grand.
Do you guys,
I'm going to do this,
you know,
and I have other opportunities and everything I have and people think I'm this
hate on the UFC or whatever.
I owe it to the EOC,
man.
I'll always be indebted to the UFC.
Uh,
people think of the problem with Dana White.
I definitely don't.
If Dana was in trouble and text me right now and said,
hey shop,
I wish you'd quit talking shit about Reebok or I
need help.
You got it,
man.
Cool.
Done.
Uh,
he,
uh,
always be a supportive,
the UCM whatever they need.
But for right now,
I gotta take a step away and focus on,
uh,
this crazy fricking entertainment podcasts career I got going on,
man.
I'm so blessed and that you are,
and I think that there's,
there's moments like that where like necessity becomes the mother of invention,
like necessity to figure out another way to generate income because the hundred
thousand dollars you were making from sponsorships,
which is 100% real and legit and certified and authenticated,
proven,
that's a lot of goddamn money you're missing out on every time you would
compete.
And so because of that,
it makes you concentrate and put even more effort into your podcast,
into your merchant said,
and I look how everything's going.
I mean,
it's,
it's insane how much money you guys are making and more important.
It's insane how many people you guys are entertaining and how many people you
guys are reaching.
It's insane.
When I did that live show the other night,
dude,
I thought Callen and never,
and our agent where honey dick in me like this thing selling out.
And I got on stage with that Mike.
I was like,
oh man.
Oh Man,
this is what I'm going to.
I love this.
This is insane,
man.
And now they want to do this tour and the the things are selling out.
It'd be tough when we say no,
you know what?
Let me go fight some monster who's been training full time,
not telling Dick Jokes and you know what I'm saying?
And selling fucking big brown shirts fulltime.
Let me go fight that guy.
I wouldn't do the game a disservice.
You know what I'm saying?
I want to do that.
So unless I could focus on it full time,
there's just no way and signing this Reebok deal,
it's not going to happen,
man.
Yeah.
I,
I completely understand where you're coming from when I've completely understand
the idea that if you're not a hundred percent focused on fighting,
it's just not something you should do.
I've always told people that finding should be a singular pursuit.
I think it's unlike any other,
any other pursuit where if you're going to do it,
you have to make sure that all your eggs are in that one basket.
I really don't think you could have one foot in the game,
one fund a foot out of the game.
I think it's real dangerous to do that with fighting and not be good.
Yeah.
Because you're going to fight some fucking guy who's all in and those all in
those,
all in murderers and they're out there.
Those all in guys,
you know,
you want it to a rumble Johnson who's all in 100% man with no other option and
listened to me and people might beg to differ.
I feel like I've won,
man.
I,
you know,
I have,
I have no brain trauma that I know of and my,
my body's in good shape.
I have this insane career right now with podcasts and the live shows and this
other Gig I get going on with TV and I feel like I've won.
And honestly I owe it to the UFC.
Man.
I'm it,
I'm indebted to them forever.
And,
um,
you know,
I'll always still watch every fight and who knows what happened in the future.
But for right now,
there's no way they could off meet anybody.
And there's no way,
there's no way I could put all this on hold holding be like,
yeah,
let me go take this flight.
Well,
it would be hard because all this has been an investment in your time and it's
also been paying off.
And it also was growing like considerably for people don't know,
like your numbers.
Like I know where you guys were a year ago and two years ago and I know where
you are now and it's,
it's this crazy exponential thing where every month that comes up and up and up
and up and up and it's because it's good.
And you guys got a weird dynamic,
you know,
accounts.
It's a fucking goof ball and,
and you know,
it's like,
he's like a builtin joke all the time.
Like he'll always say something ridiculous and you two together are funny.
Like it's a funny group.
It's funny grouping.
That's interesting thing is what I'm doing.
Listen man,
my two advisers or Joe Rogan and Brian Cowen.
What,
what the fuck?
I get the Mount Rushmore.
You know what I'm saying?
Guys who have have done shit who are saying for sure listen to me and not him.
No.
I'm assuming right now real quick.
Hey,
that's me being friendly to Callan.
Maybe it'd probably be challenge,
but the thing that will get some fucking God damn horrible advice could be
selling used electronics,
fighting a kid,
use electronics class.
Tallon was advising this fucking thing.
You want to open the pawn store?
That's a different story.
But uh,
what store a pond like,
uh,
like,
like a fucking one stars.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh,
pawn.
Yeah,
for real.
For Real.
Wait a minute.
This is the one that idea,
I thought you said a pond.
Like he wants to open up.
Okay.
Five kids funds.
That's really,
that's a weird way of looking at things.
Maybe people like ponds you wanted to sell are going off,
dude.
Oh my God,
blessed this fight is fucking crazy.
Um,
um,
but yeah,
so long story short,
I'm stepping away from the game and there's going to be no shab Reebok kits out
there.
I'm not finding when,
anytime soon.
Did they ever make a shrub Reebok kit?
Can I get one like as like a a collector's item?
I think they did for like a week and then I came out and just talked all this
shit and I'm like,
Oh shit,
pull that shit down.
Pull that shit down right now.
Did anybody buy one?
Do you get any money from those?
I'll probably like 14 cents or some shit.
I don't know the deal,
but it sure as fuck.
Not as much as selling my own shit.
He,
oh well no,
because then you get all,
exactly.
And we just released shirt and I made,
you know,
I'm doing good,
doing good,
everything's Nice.
There's no need to be struggling.
There's no one's struck more shirts than Reebok kits.
Well,
here's the reality,
you guys,
what you've done is a real show.
It's a real show.
It's just like having a TV show and people don't think it's TV show because it's
not on NBC or CBS or Fox,
but it's the same guy.
They'll be,
that's what we're filming.
November's not supposed to say.
No,
I can say that.
Oh yeah,
that's all.
We start shooting November.
We have the director,
the production team,
that's what we're doing right in APP.
So it's a,
it's a show like,
like it's a successful entertainment vehicle.
That's what it is,
you know,
and that's what podcasts are and they don't,
they seem like they're horse shit and people are used to make fun of them
before,
you know,
Howard Stern,
before he got into that thing with Ari,
he made fun of a podcast.
When Adam Carolla came on his show,
he was like,
wait,
are you,
are you hurting for money?
I'm like,
what's going on?
Know Adam Carolla owns a fucking giant warehouse.
He's got like 10 different podcasts running simultaneously.
Raking it in.
People are threatened by it.
Right.
And also the thing with podcasts and there's no,
there's no kind of standard to start a podcast.
So if Joe Schmoe and start when he can stolen.
So there's a ton of them out there.
There's some fucking awesome podcasts,
but just like anything,
there's just,
there's a ton of shitty radio shows out there.
There's a ton of Shitty TV out there,
but there's a bunch of good content out there,
man.
100% there's some real good ones.
Damn.
This dude in the white,
he keeps landing those fucking leg kicks on.
This dude,
the other guy's name,
his willingness to dam the will is wellness on the right.
Basic ass basketball shorts.
He said,
fuck it.
He didn't get the Reebok kiss.
Give me those eighth grade basketball are kicking the shit out of each other's
legs.
Straight up.
It's hurting my legs just watching this.
Oh boom.
Oh,
huge left hook.
This is a good fight,
man.
Fight,
but they're standing right in front of each other.
This is an MMA fight for sure.
Someone would be in half guard right now,
which I prefer.
You know,
it's weird,
right?
That they,
it's MMA really is the perfect sport because as cool as this is to watch guys go
off and Stan and strike,
the reality is there's so open for takedowns.
It's not realistic.
It's not a real fight.
Yeah,
it's not.
It's a difference.
It's almost like a smells like fish.
It is a fight,
but it's a kickboxing fight.
It's a fight with a,
with a set agenda,
like a fight fight.
Some shit's going to go down.
We might go to the ground,
whatever.
That's why still love the UFC three minutes as opposed to five minutes.
It's kind of interesting because it's easier to stand and strike like cardio
wise than it is to grapple and strike at the same time.
The only different differences.
If we grapple,
I can get breaks.
Maybe.
What did you fight in?
Cane.
There's no breaks.
That's how Cain breaks dudes.
True breaks you because it's going to take some breaks though.
Well,
I did Max.
It's around when he's balls deep in your Chin with his head dead five that
you're fucked and he's like taking a second off things,
going back to beat your brains.
In Junior dos Santos taking tiny little breaks.
Oh No,
he's taking years away from your life.
He's definitely incentives like,
Huh.
That's the same dude.
Yeah,
you're bat shit crazy thing.
That's the same thing that he's the same dude after that fight with our DCO.
Uh,
I've heard,
I've heard a lot of things were,
you know,
came to have the great camp.
He didn't get there.
You know,
I've heard a tenant,
we didn't get there early enough.
Correct?
It's still got his ass.
What?
Yeah.
So,
but,
but it,
this is Cain man.
So I've heard a lot of the things that went on there.
So I think they fight at sea level,
you know,
we're going to see,
but to say that fight took years off Keynes life.
No,
I don't think so.
Not like the same way.
Junior dos Santos Kane did.
Do you think,
do you have any reservations about them fighting in Brazil?
If I'm Cain and I'm like,
what the fuck the fuck's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you man?
I'm a champion.
How long are you?
Probably the wolves,
but he's,
can we some drug that's in this bitch?
Fabrizio was the champ.
They'll still be drug testing.
It'd be Brazilian drug testing.
They should be fine.
Yeah,
that'd be fine.
That works for everybody.
I think if he tore Belfort's doctors,
uh,
responsible for some,
some of that over there.
Yeah,
for sure.
He knows what he's doing.
Oh,
don't get me started.
I fought in Brazil's a,
Huh?
What?
I don't feel good.
You have the truck exhaust pouring into my locker.
You'll be fine.
Swear to God.
Swear on my life.
My coach truck exhausted,
pouring it back up.
Trucks where I fought in the trucks were backed up and on and the exhaust coming
in my locker room.
[inaudible] we're all sleepy and my coach goes pro,
bro.
Wake the fuck up.
I go,
what?
Oh,
I'm there six hours early.
By the way.
He was wake up,
dude.
Everyone and everyone like down.
He's like,
it's the truck fumes to get outta here.
So we had to go outside and warm up outside.
No true story.
That's crazy.
That's like getting drugs are weird,
man.
You're in Brazil.
You think [inaudible] you're striking coach,
you're sucking fumes from trucks.
Terrible idea.
There's a lot of things that could've gone better and that situation,
but I find it weird how life works out though.
It all leads to this.
Yeah,
it is.
How weird,
how life works out.
Well,
you know,
it doesn't always like some people are defeated by setbacks and some people you
set to to move forward.
It's like we were talking about Ryan Bader,
he's a perfect example.
I had a couple of years ago,
people were writing Ryan Bader off.
It wasn't that long ago.
I agree.
100% I agree.
Now looking at beats,
Osp beats phase Xiao,
you know,
looks fucking fantastic against Phil Davis.
Looks fantastic against Rashad.
You know,
fuck that.
I'd be,
if I didn't have this podcast and these live shows and shit right now,
I'd be in training camp getting ready for,
I'd probably some black beast on fucking fight pass black beast.
He called me on.
That's why I said it.
I was hitting it.
Yeah.
Hey Bro,
for sure.
Pick a guy can actually fight.
That'd be a fight that I would actually encourage you to probably take.
Yeah,
me too.
I do it.
I grip this Jay Leno Denim shirt bright off right now and beat him up.
He's a tough guy though.
He's a tough guy.
He was very tough.
He hits a friend,
the UFC,
they're all tough.
Not as tough as be shop.
What do you think about,
um,
uh,
the,
the steep aimia chick Ben Rothwell fight.
That's a really good fight.
That's a great fight,
man.
That,
that,
that's a tough one to call.
That's a super tough one to call.
Really.
Really?
It's in Dublin.
That's whatever.
So it's whoever Steve pays a BCP is a motherfucker coming off the Mark Hunt
fight.
It depends on which Rothwell we get.
You know what I'm saying?
Roth was confident as fuck.
And he's tough as fuck.
He hits hard.
You look at the,
you don't,
you know more than anybody,
but you look at that,
Brendan verified,
he beat the shit out of Brendan Vera.
Yeah.
With,
with me through that spinning back elbow first whenever Atlanta by heavyweight.
But the thing is is I brought he and then I come flying in.
They click some of that left hook,
which is whatever.
This is how stupid I was back then when now for me,
Ben Rothwell,
I went,
what?
I argue with my,
imagine Joe Silva.
I'm like,
it's too easy,
man.
I need something else.
Ha.
Did you really think I was too?
Yeah.
I was like,
oh,
this is such an easy fight.
So did you under estimate him 100% I thought he's this big slow guy.
Just right before we go in the cage.
My coach leaster Bolin who heads muscle farm now Tj Dillashaw is coach.
Looks at me goes,
Bro,
this is not a fucking sprint.
Let's drag his ass in the third round and submit them his know Jujitsu drags us
in third round.
Don't go crazy.
You got it.
Go in there.
Go on there.
It's spinning.
Elbow wobbled.
Fucking go crazy.
It clipped fucking idiot,
man.
I loved how he fought against Overeem dude.
Mitre own packing heat,
man.
It's scary guy with experience like that.
It's tough.
He's scary,
dude.
We'll see man suit like Steve.
Steve Bay's a motherfucker,
he's just gotta be in incredible shape for Steve Bay cause steep pays so fit.
He's so fit.
And you know,
he gained a lot of confidence in the junior dos Santos fight when five hard
rounds Dosantos in a war.
It was a really close war.
And then he goes from that to beat the shit out of Mark Hunt.
I mean steep pays on a roll right now.
This is the,
this is the only,
I think x factor in this fight is Rothwell is so fucking tough.
And Rothwell has knocked out power where Steve Bay really doesn't.
Yeah.
Steve Bay is more of a,
um,
he's a a volume guy.
Look at that.
Look at that tsunami on TV with the Rock.
Do you see that tsunami to listen dog?
The Shit is how excited.
Andres,
this is you.
This is you.
Here we go.
This is
Rena Delray having a little party.
Hey,
everything's going to be fine.
Oh my God.
Why is the ground moving?
Oh my God,
I'm in a condo.
Don't worry.
This conduct is waterproof.
That's what I'm talking about.
That kind of shit.
That kind of shit ain't nothing for the world.
I hate to tell you you're fucked to where you're at.
If that big thing comes,
we're all fucked.
C'Mon man.
Can I just can I just hate on nothing of the hammer.
Not The nail.
I got it all planned out,
bro.
I got water saved up the waters.
Lease your fucking problems.
Got Real issues,
man.
It's common.
Oh,
Steve Bay route.
Steve Pay Rothwell's a hell of a fight,
man.
I can't believe that's not the main event.
Who is it?
Duffy and Duffy employees are great,
but it's a great fight off the east.
Jo Duffy's a fucking Duffy's.
Boxing's ridiculous.
He's a very good Conor McGregor.
He's got good kicking too.
He's got a really good overall may game.
He mixes things up monster to man.
Especially at that weight class.
Yeah.
Pull a waste going.
I can't believe it.
I just can't believe steep bay.
Was he right nor two in the world.
He'll get a main event.
Is he number two now?
It's Keynes.
Gotta be
number one.
Junior dos Santos are steep.
What junior's injured right now is he?
No,
he's fine now he's fighting over to him in December.
Right.
But he was just coming off a surgery through any did Steve Bay.
But that steep ab mark with jds beat mark.
Yeah.
But junior beat steep in his last fight.
I think he's gotta be number one out.
Sub side cane.
I think Keynes got to be number one.
And then juniors gotta be number two.
No,
it would make sense Steve Base three.
Yeah.
And then our last keys for round five.
There's some fucking weird weird shit with a rating one to,
I don't know who the fuck does him.
Some of the ratings were real weird man.
Sometimes guys beat guys and they're below him.
And the ratings,
you're like wait,
it's super weird.
I don't understand how they work.
Who Decides?
That's what I'm saying.
Who the fuck the sides?
Yeah.
Like your why a hall.
Here's a perfect example.
Uriah Hall.
Where's Musashi?
Above Uriah Hall.
Weill Hall just jumped,
Spinning Back,
kick gay garb.
Musashi in the face,
flying.
Need him in the face and then beat him down for a Tko.
So you tell me how the fuck is Uriah Hall number 10 and Gay Garden was saucy is
number eight with all due respect and gay guards a great fighter.
And people like he's a better fighter.
No,
he's not talk.
And he lost.
I agree.
Uriah Hall's the better fighter you might locate gay guard Musashi's background.
Say,
well no,
you got to see gay Garmin saucy.
He beat jock array in Japan.
He beat Dan Henderson.
You know,
he,
I mean you look at his victories in the UFC and he'd go,
well,
he's gotta be the guy,
but no fire.
[inaudible] hall fought him and beat him.
He should be above them.
And the rankings,
those rankings are crazy.
100% those are crazy rankings.
Like what the fuck do you have to do to move up in the rankings if you can't
jump spinning back,
kick a guy in the face and then flying Nia guy in the face.
By the way,
in the second round.
I agree.
Yeah,
he lost the first round.
He got taken down and dominated.
But so did Anderson Silva when Anderson Silva fought shale sun in the second
time.
Well we got to still ranked shale son and above Anderson Silva after Annison
kneed him in the body and,
and,
and uh,
and stopped him in the,
in the third fight.
I don't think the second fight rather have a rhyme or reason to the banking
madness.
Like remember when they were going to pay guys based off their rank and I was
like what?
What?
That's fucking insane.
Crazy cause that's up for debate.
Right?
How,
who makes that?
I need to know.
I think it's a bunch of dude.
How's that?
That that is one of the most big go back to where it was pleased.
Hey good.
Good luck.
That ranking the lightweights.
Yeah,
but that is one of the worst ranking system situations I've ever seen.
When you win in a spectacular way,
like Uriah Hall just did and you are not were awarded by moving up in the
rankings.
That's,
that's the definition of insanity and it doesn't make any sense.
That's goofy as fuck man.
There's Jason Wellness getting a little Vaseline.
Let me see those light weight rankings.
Good.
Like how the fuck do you rank all those monsters?
That okay.
Number one,
who do we got here?
Pedis makes sense to Serone.
Makes Sense.
Normal.
Good.
Madoff three all make sense Eddie Alvarez for,
okay.
Eddie Alvarez only has one victory in the UFC though,
right?
That's tough.
So they're going based off his bride Melendez.
He'd beat Melendez.
Michael Johnson,
Michael Johnson's very high level right now he's looking real good.
Michael Johnson just lose to somebody or yeah,
he,
no,
he lost.
But he actually beat him.
But he lost the control decision to homeboy from a black house.
Great striker.
Oh yeah.
But Neal dairy,
dairy,
you should,
whereas in the ratings,
he's down at number 10 that's interesting.
So Michael Johnson is all the way up at number five and he lost.
Have Been Neil diary you.
She's number 10.
Hmm.
That is fucking interesting is shit.
But get fucking welter weight,
man.
That's a weird one because that's one were a lot of people thought that Michael
John's got a raw deal.
Yeah,
100% and I could drop.
Must Be.
And he wasn't at all the ratings.
And I'm a dairy.
Huge Fan and I think he lost that fight.
I'm a dairy.
Which fan as well?
Big Fan and he's bad.
Motherfucker.
Miles.
Jury number nine.
I thought miles,
jury and move to featherweight now isn't he?
Did he move to featherweight?
Isn't he fighting someone in the featherweight division is the next one.
I thought so too.
Hmm?
Have you ever watched his ink master?
This is a good show.
I have watched.
It seems weird to have contests on Permacol a dig it man.
Permanent artwork on someone's body.
Navarro though.
Fuck sakes,
Bro.
Easy on the eye makeup.
Huh?
I like him.
Beautiful Man.
You know what?
Don't you run?
I'm a fan.
I heard he has a hockey with Carmen Electra.
However,
if you,
you got to chill out on my makeup,
Bro.
If I'm going to continue to watch the show.
Uh,
let's see.
Welter weight out mother fucker.
Here's the dark horse in the lightweight division.
Now Thompson,
he motherfucking Ferguson.
That's your dark horse right there,
Tony.
Oh,
for sure.
Tony Ferguson's the dark horse.
First of all,
he's the hardest hitter and the entire division.
He spooky too.
There's something spooky about him.
He's so game.
It's insane.
He's,
he's a bad motherfucker,
dude,
bro.
How do you have Kelvin ranked 15 didn't he?
Did Calvin when his last fight at one 85 and then they allowed them to fight at
one 70 again.
That's what happened.
Right.
Beat Nate.
That's right.
The shit out of Nate.
And they forced him out.
Yeah.
That was the sad fight.
I did not enjoy that fight.
Fucking terrible.
And Nate's still fighting.
Uh,
anyways.
How about Hendrix?
How about your boy Hendrix?
Yeah.
Are they gonna make him fight a middleweight now?
He said he's not fighting middle age,
so he's going to go one more time.
It went 70.
Well,
how's he going to do that?
That would cause Dana White's it.
I consider him a minute wait,
and I miss wait,
fucked everybody up.
Fucked up.
Tyrone's would tell a guy what weight to fight it.
Especially your Johny Hendricks.
Well you can if you won't give them a fight at one 70 because you got to such a
talent rich division.
I mean look at what you got down there at welterweight.
Look at this.
You got Rory Macdonald,
Tyron Woodley,
you got Hendrix,
then you go those guys,
guest stars and hacks.
But people don't pay to see Hendrix like they pay to see like a George Saint
Pierre or like a,
they paid to see,
you know,
like some of the bigger stars in the UFC because a lot of people thought that
Hendrix,
like in some of his victories,
like the Matte Brown fight,
they thought that it wasn't that exciting.
True.
See,
I disagree.
I'll pay to see that guy any day of the week,
but I think he's fighting smart.
I agree.
I liked that he uses his wrestling bro.
Besides Robbie Lawler,
who's the most sane guy in the division?
Comments.
Pretty God damn exciting.
But he's been gone for a while,
but he's excited.
It's fun.
But he just knocked out Taco Alvarez with nasty elbow.
Matt Brown is about as exciting as a fucking human being can get.
I'm saying exciting.
I'm saying to a bigger named Johnny Hendricks Bolt Near.
Those guys are bigger than Hendricks conduct.
You can say,
but he's been gone for awhile.
Interests tend to cause a big name,
Bro.
He's a big name,
but I don't necessarily know how that translates to pay per view buys,
which at the end of the day is all they care.
Huge fat.
I'm just saying a guy like Johnny Hendricks at what is the a two time champion?
You can't say,
Oh,
you got to set it when 85 if he's like,
no,
I'm making it what you do.
If he doesn't make the weight more than once and he's already missed the weight
twice,
he's missed.
Wait twice and barely made it for one of the Lawler.
He came in way over.
Wait for this to like 26 pounds when I heard him.
Come on.
Yeah,
he was heavy as fuck.
Meanwhile,
Joe Schilling is about to fucking throw down.
Let's do this.
It now,
stitch him up.
This is a big,
big fight and hit the guy.
He's fighting.
Chasing wellness is a fucking beast.
Wellness's nasty.
Really,
really hard.
Striker man.
Your boy Schilling flex and them.
I'm not mad at it either.
The body,
that was pretty yoked audit up.
This is a good one.
It's a good matchup.
Stylist at 24 24 and nasty dude.
He's real good man.
Yeah,
that,
that welterweight division is tough.
Yeah,
it's tough.
How's Hendricks do at one 85 how's he match up with 85 minutes for?
I don't like it.
How's he meant?
Okay.
You gotta go to the champ.
You go to the top of the,
scroll down to middle eight for me.
Jamie.
When whenever you do that,
you go to the top of the heap.
How does he match up with the champ?
Bad idea.
Other than that,
I like a good,
I liked them.
Please.
How does he match up with Luke?
Rockhold not so good.
How's the matchup with joc right and not so good.
How's he matchup with Yoel Romero not so like disagree.
Yoel Romero.
I think he'd beat too.
I'll remember like,
oh my God.
Are you crazy?
That one hurts my feeling.
Are you serious?
Yoel Romero was a monster.
UFC champ.
Yeah,
he's big.
You see what he did to Leo Machida in his last fight?
Did he did fuck my boy monster.
He's a monster.
How dare you.
He is,
but at one 70 Johnny Hendricks is five eight he's small.
He's five.
Eight.
He small.
Yeah.
I mean when I stand next to him in the octagon and I have shoes on,
I'm taller than him.
If I'm taller than you,
you can't fight Yoel Romero.
That's just how the rules are.
You and Callan and this height thing.
Well,
no,
I'm sure DC short.
I'm just saying tiny fucking kicked up,
but DC's big in a different way.
I don't think Hendrick's is that big.
I think Hendrick's just carries too much body fat.
I think Hendricks at one 70 cause 100% be the champ again.
100% a hundred percent for sure.
Figure it out.
Hendrix,
when he's on,
I mean you got to look at his knockouts of Martin Kampmann and John Fitch.
He's a fucking monster when he's on,
I mean you always have to look at a guy though based on his last fight.
That's the unfortunate thing about fighting.
They always say you're only as good as your last fight.
While his last fight,
I thought he fought pretty fucking good,
but then his fight that was supposed to be his last fight.
He didn't make the weight.
That's where the controversy lies.
The controversy lies is lack of discipline and coming into training camp have a
heavy more than once.
I mean not learning his lesson when he came in super fit for the map.
Brown fight look great.
Sid,
he got ahold of his meal prep.
It's tough to argue this fight.
He came into camp 10 pounds heavier than his last camp according to adult shake.
10 pounds is a lot man.
Well,
he didn't work with Delta for this gap though,
but dolce knows what he came in at.
Doody came in at this camp versus what he came in at the last camp.
Everybody knows it.
I mean they've all admitted it.
He admitted it when he talks about when he's,
it was camp went wrong,
he talked about it and then you got to get a kidney stone.
Can't do it at this level.
What the fuck we do and might have an eating disorder.
You know,
we were talking earlier about being addicted to shit.
He might be addicted to eating and it might,
it might be addicted to eating and then if he is,
I am Paul.
His discipline,
the discipline of being a fighter,
you know,
it might be so overwhelming that when he's not doing it,
he just a gorgeous the fuck up dude.
He'll get to his level that have discipline.
I don't know what's going on.
Their discipline and addiction sometimes our next door neighbor's got that
middle weight division.
Here we go.
Joe Schilling,
Jason Wellness.
Here we go.
Come on.
Let's just,
how do you get nervous when your friends fight?
Fuck yes.
Fuck yeah to always.
Oh always.
No way around it.
Nope.
That's just part of the worst.
It's part of the sport.
I can't imagine my family watch me fight.
How about if your son was fighting?
My found daughter starts fighting.
Oh,
Jesus Dodgers.
Next Ronda Rousey.
Whoa.
Jason Walsall.
Nice led Jesus Christ.
Should I spinning back fist but showing she leaves a bad motherfucker too.
Especially at kickboxing.
Kickboxing is his shit.
His defense is tighter at kickboxing.
It's just this movements and nasty as fuck.
Oh,
he's excellent.
And when he doesn't have to worry about being taken down,
then he gets loose loose.
Oh,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He looks so much better.
The kit has kickboxing way better.
Yeah.
He's just,
he looks like a world champion.
Just be the best of the load at this.
Fuck.
MMA.
Yeah.
Let's go run this Joe and listening.
Well we got,
we assume he wins and we still fight.
And Jason Wellness.
We'll look at that.
See,
wellness is not junk,
but God Damn Joe looks aggressive at all witnesses defect.
Holy Shit.
It is.
But Joe Schilling is lighten them up with those front kicks to the body to boom
is another one.
Son and your boy shelling of the smoke shop sponsor.
He likes the weed.
Oh well Michelle kick with nasty damn shelling us eating him up though.
Showing of the affliction sponsor too.
Damn affliction.
Still alive affliction said God dammit.
Rybak the one guy died and they got rid of Tom Atencio so who the fuck is
affliction so and bottom out just like the bought out.
Tap Out.
Wow.
That's interesting bro.
I used to rock those affliction shirts with like fucking both silver and angel
wings and it said like fade or on the back while I was friends with Atencio and
I liked what he did for fighters.
He sponsored a lot of fighters and I uh,
I supported them because of that.
Like I didn't need the affliction of money they were giving me.
It wasn't that much,
it was just a little bit,
but in my mind I thought it was a good idea to support a company that was given
fighters a lot of money.
They were sponsoring a lot of fighters and they put together that affliction MMA
card and gave people a shitload of money.
Damn.
Joe Schilling looks good.
They fucked up on that card though.
They put all their money on that one card and it was so dope.
The card was stacked.
Damn.
Shilling.
Look real loose,
dropping his hands,
moving light.
His foot works ridiculous and is looks real frustrated.
He's kind of like paralyzed a man.
He's combinations.
He might just be weathering the storm.
He might be or it might be getting his ass.
He this five rounds so they go five rounds.
Just going to title.
It's a good question because it's the main event.
Damn Joe shelling with the movement.
Ooh Look
good shows married.
Yeah,
he's got,
well he's got a woman that's got some kids.
I think as you engage with basically married though basically
what's going on,
what happened or free stepped in,
stop something worn something.
I don't,
I don't know what happened.
Damn.
Throwing up front kicks.
He though when you're a tall fighter like that does front kicks to the body are
really nice.
Yeah.
He's been a nice option.
Tough to counter that man.
Good defense here by shilling to,
he's is a different animal when he's kickbox he's confident.
He's confident.
It's a sport is defense is way better with those big gloves is like super used
to.
It can also sound risk more.
Yup.
And he's not worried about being taken down so he could do his shit.
We'll have to talk them into fighting only kickboxing.
Yeah,
give me an hour with them.
Look at this man.
God Damn,
he's looking good.
Boom Bang Bang.
One to definitely I like,
I like how he's throwing the straight right and then a hard jab behind it too.
You know like after that right hand.
Like a lot of MMA fighters especially,
they'll pull back and then look for either another right hand or whatever.
He stepping in hard with that jam.
Tell you what,
I don't like that Magnus Urena and up here he full.
Come on.
Well I don't think this sport,
I don't think the sport gets the attention that it deserves.
You know,
as excited as you and I were for this fight and this card like to me this is
like an opportunity to watch high level fighting.
Like whether or not it's MMA or it kicked off.
I like,
like I think the ultimate sport is MMA.
It always will be the ultimate sport.
But when I want to watch the best expression of striking technique,
there's certain shit that you only see when you watch my tie or you only see
when you watch kickboxing and this is it right here.
Like these kind of Duke it out battles.
True.
I don't get like,
don't get me wrong and I fucked him some glory kickboxing,
but I don't get as excited or crunk ignore or crunk for this as I do for like a
main event in the UFC.
So different kind of,
yeah.
Excitement.
Well I do because Joe is my friend and I support him,
but I,
I feel,
yeah,
but if you know,
if you're watching like the very best guys in the world,
go at it in any discipline.
It's fun.
Whether it's boxing,
you know,
you watch Manny Pacquiao versus Mayweather.
It's still fun.
Hell yeah,
dude.
Wrestling.
Yeah,
the top world.
You know what I'm saying?
But I still,
the best wrestling is even fun to watch,
but I think this is way better than boxing.
I really do.
I think this is oh big left hand from Joe Schilling.
God Damn Dude.
He looks so fucking good tonight.
He is on it,
man.
He was all over it.
The left hook.
I bet he comes in.
We just slipped,
smoked so smooth.
Everything looks smooth.
His defense,
everything.
He's not wasting anything is he?
No,
no.
He's,
he's fighting nice and find it very nice.
Very light on his feet.
Never stand stationary mics and shit up very well
to him.
I like how he's like moving out and in well lifts up for a front kick and then
punches you in the face and then he's out.
Yeah.
You don't know what the fuck is going on.
What's a Rashad's boy?
He's corner Tyrone's.
Paul,
what's his deal on stern?
I know he's asking date and white for a fight.
He wants money,
you know,
he's like,
I want to be paid what I deserve.
He's one of the best strikers on the planet earth.
Haunted does said if I'm going to fight an MMA,
he goes,
I want to be treated like I get treated in kickbox.
They're trying to give them that basic as contract.
What are they saying to,
uh,
Fiko the go low or something like that.
I Dunno what they're offering him.
I don't know what they're offering him.
I really have no idea.
He just needs the exposure.
I think going to take a um,
a point away here.
What's going on in low kick?
Nope.
No,
I can definitely morning.
They won't walk you around and say 1.1 point right when they take they lift,
shitty rocked him again.
I feel like Schilling got,
oh Jason Walnuts throws hard shots to,
Oh fuck.
Oh Shit.
Schillings holding on man.
He got cracked.
That was a big,
big,
big punch by wellness.
Oh my God.
Oh my God again bro.
Oh fuck.
He got hurt.
He got his really a right hand.
Wellness is all over him.
He's got a claim and use that MMA grappling.
Yeah.
He's got a claim.
He's his.
She had clear the cobwebs right now it's got to clear the cobwebs.
That's the scary thing about wellness man is at Keio power.
Joe Gets that clench too.
He got hurt bad.
And this round.
I see a powerful Matt Brown and the crowd.
He does his camps there.
Now does he yell at elevation?
Yup.
Is everybody going to go to elevation that Mussel farms coming with that cash?
You think so?
Rampage is one of the first guys to go there,
right?
He did like he did a camp there when they first opened up but he didn't like it
again.
Damn wellness.
It's hard dude.
Someone lost their mouthpiece.
It's your boy.
Is it pretty sure it's a type move though.
Cause you get a break that move outside of the road?
I don't think so.
I don't think it's the end of the round dude.
Yeah.
So you get that.
You get that break.
Damn boy lost that round.
Yeah.
Did he tell,
did he knock him down earlier in the round now?
No,
not really.
That was the first round,
was it?
Boom.
Oh fuck.
Was that this round?
The very beginning.
God,
that's tough man.
That's better than knockdowns bigger because showing was it?
Yeah.
That's bigger.
He was wobbled too.
That was a real knockdown dude that's an even round knew cause he knocked him
down.
Shilling got fucked up.
He got tagged for sure.
But look,
he used good defense and clinched up knockdowns and kickboxing or big dude,
just like knock downs in boxing.
They were like a takedown MMA fight where you get rocked.
Like if a guy gets dropped in an MMA fight and another guy lands fights like
punches like that,
that's a hard fight to score.
Maybe it's a nine nine round.
That's what I'm saying.
I could be nine nine but the knocked down his big dude cause I wouldn't give
them a 10 I wouldn't give him a ten eight if you,
what's going on the fights over what's happening?
What do you do?
Break his foot.
Oh Shit.
Joe Schilling one.
What happened?
Broke his foot.
Did he break his foot?
Oh Wow.
That's a bomb.
But it was a good fight.
Good for us to have him.
Congrats the Joe Schilling.
But after having a round like that where he had Schilling and all kinds of
trouble,
that's a bummer.
That's a big victory for Shung Tracy [inaudible] ankle man.
He broke his foot or his ankle.
Something's broken.
No Shit.
You throw the spreads that has it happened all the time.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's fucked shit.
If he's rapping.
Yeah.
Year Rodriguez and the first round is fine.
That mother fucker.
Fuck kid two rounds like that.
Move in and shoot.
I text you.
You imagine that Kit's champion from Mexico.
What?
With his personality and his style get fuck yeah man.
Dude texted and congrats
to Joe Schilling.
Yeah.
Here's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
He's so exciting.
He's so versatile.
His Jujitsu,
everything is Jujitsu's nasty.
His take down defense is excellent.
Getting better.
Yeah.
It's,
it's excellent for a guy to throw his kicks like he does though.
He's throwing wild shit all the time.
Is that Jackson's now too?
Is he tried to work on his wrestling?
That's a good move.
There's a bunch of like really good high level camps right now,
so it's a super times.
Such a good time for MMA and guys aren't sparring as much and got,
you know,
it's good.
It's a great time for him.
Yeah,
it's a great time for two oh five how excited is to,
Oh fuck.
It's MMA.
N n you know,
just the,
not just the UFC,
but even Beltour like the,
like if you look at some of the guys they have,
like there's some talent like all throughout,
across an a May.
Now the only thing I,
here's,
here's a problem.
Who the fuck is fade or going to fight to find some one to know?
Dude,
come on.
I'm pretty sure they announced he's fighting to want to know guy calm.
They reneged it.
Yeah.
No,
I'm almost positive.
I saw that.
Oh God.
This could be bro Science.
This could be MMA scientists at night be lying.
Cause I left hand again.
He dropped him with,
but here's this big dude.
Boom.
That's right on the money.
He caught him on the money and then he rock going kid.
He fought smart.
They're covering up.
Oh,
he walked him a couple times after that and that's it.
Third round couldn't come out.
Good for Shelly.
Yeah.
That's gotta be a giant relief for him too.
After that second round.
Who was stuck around.
That was scary.
He showed a good chin though.
Especially for a guy that got knocked out in his last fight.
See opponent would be s whatever,
whatever the fuck that.
Who's the opponent?
No.
Who she's Akihabara say's record below that area.
Hawaii.
It make it was picked up on it.
No,
that's trolling.
Keeping Gi deep is there trolling.
That's the internet suddenly fucks MMA fighting lesson that sing jai deep guy.
That is a guy that on my message board,
they joke around about him being the big threat to Cain Velasquez.
He's just like really overweight Indian guy.
It's a joke.
This is a troll.
The honey Dick.
They're trolling.
All right.
It's the Internet.
Tony.
Somebody that role Aoki sock was for reals.
Soccer whales.
He'll keep her sock robis for reals.
I'll come on.
I swear to God.
I thought Soccer Rama was done.
Oh,
Kenny Florian was in Japan and rolled with a oak.
He was like,
who are you fighting next?
And he said,
Suck Rama.
Kenny's like what?
It's a bummer.
Right?
Well,
here's a problem and he'll can Aoki can strike,
you know,
I mean,
soccer opposite bigger guy,
but he okay.
Strike,
he's not that bad.
I think Sakharova has so many miles on them.
Dude.
Aoki striking compared to soccer.
I right now he's fucking Joe.
Shelley.
Yeah.
Ramos.
He's taken so many fucking beatings.
Moore's 10 braces.
Yeah.
Think if Aoki gets hold of one of those old as ankles to rip it off,
like tales from the crypt.
Ooh.
I think grappling wise,
he's still very competent.
Gratis,
gratis.
Did you see him fighting metamorris yeah.
Gets Hanzo.
Yeah.
But you know,
he was able to go to a draw with Henzel.
I agree.
And handles a monster and one of my favorite people that ever grace this earth,
however Aoki.
That's,
uh,
that's some shit,
man.
As much smaller too.
He was fought at lightweight where a Sakharova fuck Conan his first UFC fight.
True.
Sacro has been through some shit much miles,
man.
Dude,
that fight,
first of all,
the Vandelay knock outs were horrible,
horrific.
And then the knockout that might've been even worse as the Melvin Manhoef one.
Oof.
Yeah.
This is uh,
an interesting fight.
Shilling knocked him down the left hand too.
It's an interesting thing about Schilling is I think it was a straight left.
Um,
Schilling fights pretty good off both sides.
Yeah.
He's a freak striking lifespan.
Good fight man.
It was a good fight.
Interesting.
It would have been interesting to see.
I'm super happy for Joe.
Hell yeah.
As long as you get a win.
If he's your friend who gives a fuck how it happened,
you know what I'm saying?
Exactly.
All right.
I'm going to the comedy store.
Boom.
Get it done down to round two fighter and the kid fighter and the kid.
What is the,
what does your website t f a t k.com.
Listen,
your fans are not bright enough to put all this basically.
T fat k t k t fat k.com.
Just drop so shit.
Brennan shop on Twitter.
Didn't you guys have Zombie versions of some of your shirts on?
Rolling.
Nice marketing genius.
Boom with a beautiful part in his hair.
All right,
you fucks.
We'll be back next week.
We've got a star studded lineup.
Next week.
Next week's banging a thank you so much for tuning in.
Thanks for all the love and we'll see soon.
Big Kiss.
Thanks man.